rumors of a Top Gun - please say it's
true it's true I'm gonna start filming
it probably in the next year oh I know
there you have it straight from maverick
cameras we'll start rolling on a Top Gun
sequel 31 years after the original which
is so exciting but the big question is
can they still play volleyball after all
these years was that seen about the
volleyball or the shirtless men where
they certain less I don't even notice
come on but by the way judging from some
of this crazy stunts that Tom continues
to pull off I think he can handle
volleyball yeah I think so I mean the
man's fearless just look at these new
scenes from the mummy
female mummy what's her story it grabs
my attention she's got plans for you now
worse fates than there
Tom gets his but he had to do it by a
woman okay
not just any woman and undead super
scary mummy played by sofia boutella but
behind the scenes Cruz is still de I do
all my own stunts man you see him at 54
years old getting thrown 20 feet strung
by a wire he's in the way of a speeding
bus and then jumps inside for this super
cool action shot he runs he jumps your
bells
he balls out of cars and he goes
one-on-one against Russell Crowe all
with a smile my chest I would love to
slam my head against the wall grrrrrr
Russell Crowe in your film playing
doctor credible mister head how is he in
your songs in Creole e yeah that's
really great fight scene between the two
of us which is really was blast doing
every man for himself
yeah it's a bit of martial arts a bit of
boxing there's some wild work it's a
couple of rugby moves on particular back
slam onto the desk which I think all
right over theatres when you see it
that's one of the world's richest actors
here's how you know Tom is worth every
penny no matter what Cruz will always
get the shot
in the world yeah who could find the VA
for me to girl great time yeah it's
really made it mean it's really big
[Music]